[Music]  Selena Gomez gets new matching tattoos  with the 13 reasons why cast if you're  listening to this tape you're one of the  reasons why in honor of the buzz around  her new Netflix series Selena revealed  on her Instagram story she got inked  with her cast mates and the taps have a  special meaning  the trio shared pigs proudly showing off  their semicolon wrist tattoos actress  Alicia Bois explained the subtle ink has  to do with projects semicolon a movement  dedicated to giving hope to those  suffering from depression and thoughts  of suicide the series deals with those  issues which is why Selena told ET she  was proud to executive produce the  project I want people to know that every  every single life is valuable that their  voice can be heard and that there are  people who are willing to be there for  them  [Music]  you